I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hi everybody. Hello from our closets. Still here. Still in our closets. Still surrounded by Josh's many, many hats. So many baseball hats. So many. Does he have a favorite? Can we get him on the pod to ask him to give us a breakdown of these hats? Are they significant emotionally in some way? Do they represent a team he loves? I mean, no, I think Josh is all about the
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。来自我们衣帽间的问候。依然在这里。依然在我们的衣帽间里。周围依然全是乔什的数不清的帽子。好多棒球帽。太多了。他有最喜欢的吗？我们能请他上播客，让他给我们讲讲这些帽子吗？它们在某种程度上具有什么情感意义吗？它们代表了他热爱的某支球队吗？我的意思是，没有，我觉得乔什只注重
fit. And it looks like he loves the Patagonia kind of trucker looking hat. It does with the adjustable band thing, the little plastic snappies. Uh huh. Josh, I hope you are excited that we shared. Listen, there's other things in the closet right over my shoulder. I notice all the time that there's the, um, what's the stuff they spray in their shoes, Jenna? The breeze? No, all dudes do this. They spray that stuff in their shoes. Odor eaters? Yes, yes. Anyway, oh, now Josh, you're really happy. I've shared with everyone that you spray your shoes. Well, because we need to talk about this longer, I am really curious about the very bright red pair of shoes over your shoulder in the shoe cubby. Who's are those? Oh, those
合身度。看起来他喜欢巴塔哥尼亚那种卡车司机风格的帽子。确实是的，带有可调节带子和那些小塑料按扣。呃，哼。乔什，希望你听到我们分享这些会感到兴奋。听着，就在我肩膀正后方的衣帽间里还有别的东西。我经常注意到，嗯，珍娜，那是他们喷在鞋子里的东西吗？气味消除剂？不，所有老兄都这样。他们把那种东西喷在鞋子里。除臭剂？是的，是的。总之，哦，现在乔什，你可真高兴。我跟所有人分享了你喷鞋子的事。好吧，因为我们需要更深入地讨论这个，我对你鞋架上、你肩膀后面那双极其鲜艳的红鞋子非常好奇。那是谁的？哦，那些
are my red converse. Okay, so here's the thing. Yes, this is Josh's closet, but I occupy most of the shoe space. I have lots of shoes. You have overflow that goes into his closet. Yeah, he's real happy about it. Well, guys, it's what you're here for, a breakdown of Angela's closet. Next week, we'll do my closet. But this week, we are talking about chair model. It's so good. Season four, episode 14, written by BJ Novak, directed by Jeffrey Blitz. With a duo like that, you know, it's going to be good. I love the simple idea that Michael has a thing for the model in a chair catalog. I just love how simple and perfect that is. Yes. Let me give you a summary. Do it. Michael is unable to pick a new chair
是我的红匡威帆布鞋。好吧，事情是这样的。是的，这是乔什的衣帽间，但我占据了大部分鞋子空间。我有很多鞋子。你的溢出鞋子都跑到他的衣帽间去了。对，他对此可高兴了。好吧，各位，这就是你们来这里的目的，剖析安吉拉的衣帽间。下周，我们要整理我的衣帽间。但本周，我们要聊的是椅模。太棒了。第四季第十四集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，杰弗里·布利茨导演。有这样的王牌组合，你知道这一集肯定会很精彩。我喜欢这个简单的设定：迈克尔迷上了椅子目录里的模特。我只是觉得这个设定又简单又完美。是的。让我给你做个总结。说吧。
for his office after he becomes infatuated with a woman modeling office chairs in a catalog. He decides he's ready to rejoin the dating pool. He's inspired by his love of the chair model. Meanwhile, the Dunder Mifflin parking spaces are being used by a construction crew doing work for WB Jones. And the staff of Dunder Mifflin has to park in a satellite lot. Kevin and Andy joined forces to confront the other bosses of the Scranton Business Park to reclaim their places in the main lot. Simple storylines, absolute perfection. Also, absolutely true. Yeah. You know, I had to park in a satellite lot when I had my admin job. If you were an executive, you could park in the parking lot of the building,
迈克尔在目录中迷上了一位办公室椅子模特后，无法为自己的办公室挑选新椅子。受到他对椅模热爱的启发，他决定准备重新回到约会市场。与此同时，邓德米夫林的停车场被一个为WB琼斯工作的施工队占用了，邓德米夫林的员工不得不把车停在卫星停车场。凯文和安迪联手与斯克兰顿商业园的其他老板对峙，以夺回他们在主停车场的位置。简单的故事情节，绝对的完美。而且，绝对真实。是的。你知道的，我做行政工作时也得把车停在卫星停车场。如果你是个高管，你就能把车停在大楼的停车场里，
this high rise in downtown Los Angeles. Yeah. I did not get a parking space. I had to park in a satellite lot that was about a half a mile away, and it wasn't a big deal except for on days that it rained. Well, here's the thing. You know where you rank in a company by where you park. Oh, yeah. Well, Michael has a spot right up front. He's not concerned. Well, later, he's going to try to imagine what it would be like if he didn't have that spot. But it takes two employees angrily confronting him for him to get there. What are our fast facts, Jenna? Fast fact number one, the original title of this episode was Michael Dating. But they realized that they would have to release the name of the episode
洛杉矶市中心的高层建筑。是的。我没有停车位。我不得不把车停在一个大约半英里外的卫星停车场，除了下雨天之外这不算什么大事。好吧，事情是这样的。你从停车的地方就能看出你在公司里的地位。哦，是的。好吧，迈克尔的停车位就在最前面。他一点也不担心。不过后来，他会试着想象如果没有那个车位会是什么样。但那是两个员工愤怒地与他当面对峙后，他才意识到这一点的。我们的速记事实是什么，珍娜？速记事实一，这一集的最初标题是“迈克尔约会”。但他们意识到他们必须在
before dinner party had aired. Oh, and they didn't want that. They didn't want to ruin the surprise about Jan and Michael's breakup, right? Yes. So they changed the name of the episode to parking. But then they felt, well, while it's a big part of the episode, it's not the main storyline of the episode. So they eventually settled on chair model, which I personally love. I mean, when you see that, aren't you intrigued? I'm so intrigued. What is this episode going to be about? Chair model. I'm more intrigued than parking. I'll say that. They picked the right one. All right. Fast fact number two, I think we need to do a little breakdown of the Scranton Business Park five families. I mean, it's like good
《晚宴派对》播出前公布这一集的名称。哦，他们不想那样。他们不想毁掉关于简和迈克尔分手的惊喜，对吧？是的。所以他们把这一集的名称改成了“停车”。但后来他们觉得，虽然停车是这一集的重要部分，但它并不是这一集的主线剧情。所以他们最终决定叫“椅模”，我个人非常喜欢。我的意思是，当你看到这个名字时，难道你不觉得好奇吗？我太好奇了。这一集到底要讲什么？椅模。我对这个名字的好奇心远胜于停车。我得这么说。他们选对了。好了。速记事实二，我觉得我们需要稍微剖析一下斯克兰顿商业园的五大家族。我的意思是，这就像
fellas. It is. All right. Here are the bosses of the five families, Michael Scott, of course, of Vance, Vance refrigeration. Then there is WB Jones from WB Jones Heating and Air. He was played by Barry Sigismundi, Bill Cress of Cress Tool and Die, who was played by Terrence Beaser. And finally, Paul Faust of Disaster Kits Limited, who was played by Paul Faust. This is an amazing story. And it all starts when an actual man named Paul Faust came to visit the set of the office. Yes. So I have known Paul Faust for years. We used to be related by marriage and I reached out to him and he is just such a hoot. And he sent in all of these fantastic audio clips about his day on set. They are amazing. And in this
好家伙。确实如此。好吧。以下是五大家族的老板，迈克尔·斯科特，当然还有万斯制冷公司的万斯。然后是来自万斯暖通空调公司的WB琼斯。他由巴里·西吉斯穆迪饰演，还有克雷斯模具公司的比尔·克雷斯，由特伦斯·比瑟饰演。最后是灾难救援包有限公司的保罗·浮士德，由保罗·浮士德饰演。这是一个神奇的故事。这一切都始于一个名叫保罗·浮士德的真实人物来参观《办公室》的片场。是的。所以我和保罗·浮士德认识好多年了。我们过去曾是姻亲，我联系了他，他真的是个超级有趣的人。他发来了所有这些关于他在片场度过的一天的精彩音频片段。它们太棒了。而在
first one, he explains exactly how he got the role on the show. Sam, you got to play this clip. Hey, office ladies and office fans. This is Paul Faust, a cool guy, Paul. I want to tell you how I got a part of the show. So I was out in LA on business and decided to visit the set because my cousins are part of the office. And when I was out there and met the writers and I kind of told them one of my companies and what I did, which was a company that sells disaster kits. And Greg had said, this is my cousin. He's a little nuts. Tell him what you do. I told him about the company. And when I walked out of the room, unbeknownst to me, BJ Novak said, that guy's got to be a character on the show. So
第一个片段中，他准确地解释了他是如何获得剧中角色的。萨姆，你得播这段音频。嘿，办公室女士们和办公室粉丝们。我是保罗·浮士德，一个酷家伙，保罗。我想告诉你们我是怎么得到这个角色的。当时我在洛杉矶出差，决定去片场参观，因为我的表亲们参与了《办公室》。当我在那里见到编剧时，我顺便跟他们聊了聊我的几家公司以及我是做什么的，其中一家公司是卖灾难救援包的。格雷格说，这是我表弟。他脑子有点问题。告诉他们你是做什么的。我向他们介绍了这家公司。当我走出房间时，在我不知情的情况下，BJ·诺瓦克说，这家伙必须得在剧里演个角色。所以
he wrote a part based on me and the day before they shot the scene, they hadn't found an actor to play the part. So I got a call asking me if I wanted to audition to play the part. And long story short, I got the part, got to fly out and be part of the awesome show and play myself. So that's how I got to be on the, uh, on the show. It's really a story only can happen in Hollywood. I mean, that's bonkers. I know he's literally playing himself. But what's bonkers to me about it was that they did hold auditions. They held auditions for this role. And the night before they just had not found someone who could play Paul Faust. So they're like, how about Paul Faust? Paul really sells disaster kits. That's real.
他根据我写了一个角色，就在他们拍摄这场戏的前一天，他们还没有找到演员来演这个角色。所以我接到一个电话，问我想不想去试镜演这个角色。长话短说，我得到了这个角色，得以飞过去参演这部超棒的剧，并且扮演我自己。所以这就是我如何参与到这部剧中的。这真的是一个只能在好莱坞发生的故事。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我知道他实际上是在扮演他自己。但对我来说最疯狂的是，他们确实举行了试镜。他们为这个角色举行了试镜。就在前一天晚上，他们偏偏没有找到能演保罗·浮士德的人。所以他们想，保罗·浮士德怎么样？保罗真的卖灾难救援包。那是真的。
What is his company? Oh yeah. And Angela, he talked about that in this next clip. I think one of the most unique things about me being in the office was that I actually played myself. When I went out to LA and I was listening and I went to the set, I talked about one of the businesses I run, which is a company called 1-800-PREPARE, 1-800-PREPARE.com, where we actually sell disaster kits and prepare this kit. So I talked about it and that's what DJ had picked up on. And so he wrote a part called about Cool Guy Paul, the owner of Disaster Kits Limited. And yes, I still own that company. We still sell disaster kits. So I think I wanted a few people who played himself on TV with his real name in a real
他的公司叫什么名字？哦，是的。安吉拉，他在接下来的这个片段里谈到了这一点。我觉得我参演《办公室》最独特的一点就是我实际上是在演我自己。当我去了洛杉矶，我在听，也去了片场，我谈到了我经营的一家企业，也就是一家名为1-800-PREPARE，1-800-PREPARE.com的公司，我们在那里真正销售灾难救援包并准备这个急救包。所以我谈到了这个，这也是DJ注意到的地方。所以他写了一个关于酷家伙保罗的角色，他是灾难救援包有限公司的老板。是的，我仍然拥有这家公司。我们仍然销售灾难救援包。所以我想我是少数几个在电视上用自己的真名扮演自己，并且经营着一家真实
business that he runs, which was kind of cool. So we asked Paul, how did he prepare to have these scenes? He's not an actor. He's not used to learning lines or where to sit, you know, how to navigate a set and all that kind of stuff. And here's what he had to say. So I got this part, let's say on a Thursday and I had, we were shooting Friday morning. So I had about a good 10 hours to learn my five or six lines. So I'm studying, studying them on the plane. I'm reading them. I didn't sleep. I studied them. So we go there and this whole experience happens and you're nervous and there's a lot of people around.
公司的企业的人，这真是太酷了。所以我们问保罗，他是如何为这些场景做准备的？他不是演员。他不习惯背台词，不习惯知道该坐在哪里，你知道的，如何驾驭片场以及所有诸如此类的事情。以下是他的回答。所以我是说在周四得到了这个角色，我们周五早上就要拍。所以我大概有整整100分钟来学习我的五六句台词。所以我一直在学，在飞机上研究它们。我在读它们。我没睡觉。我一直在学。所以我们去了那里，整个经历发生了，你很紧张，周围有很多人。
And I had, I had 10 hours to learn a bunch of lines. So I was able to do it and we knocked it out and, and I got it done and I was like, great, I finished. And then all of a sudden somebody came in and they threw these new scripts down. They said, okay, here's the altered ending. Let's take a five minute break, learn our lines and come back to you. And I'm like, wait, wait, what am I five minutes? What? I had 10 hours to learn my lines. Five minutes. I'm not learning new lines. So I raced out the hallway, had to study, learn all the lines, learn when I came in and whatever, a lot of doing it, knocking it out, getting it done right. And again, life experience with amazing people who were just so supportive
我有10个小时来学一堆台词。所以我成功做到了，我们一鼓作气搞定了，我当时想，太棒了，我完成了。然后突然有人进来，把这些新剧本扔在桌上。他们说，好吧，这是修改后的结局。我们休息五分钟，学一下台词，然后回来找你。我说，等等，等等，我五分钟？什么？我有10个小时来学台词。五分钟？我可不学新台词。所以我冲到走廊里，不得不学习，学完所有的台词，学我什么时候出场，管他呢，反复练习，一鼓作气，搞定它。再次强调，这是一次与那些非常支持我的优秀人们一起经历的生活体验，
that I was glad that I was able to be a tiny part of this amazing family. Well, Angela, I found an interview with Paul and he said that he landed in LA at 1 30 in the morning. The airline lost his luggage. So he had no luggage. He got to his hotel and went to sleep about 3 15 in the morning and he had to be up at five a.m. for work. So after all of that, I'm kind of amazed. I would have been loopy. I would have been able to learn new lines. No. And I think of Paul just like he's had no sleep. He's probably in the same underwear because they lost his bag. And you know, and now he's like, he thought he reached the finish line and then they hand him this whole new task. Well, Paul sent a
我很高兴自己能够成为这个伟大大家庭中微小的一部分。好吧，安吉拉，我找到了一个对保罗的采访，他说他是在凌晨1点半降落在洛杉矶的。航空公司弄丢了他的行李。所以他没有行李。他到达酒店后大约在凌晨3点15分上床睡觉，为了工作他早上5点钟就得起床。所以在经历了这一切之后，我有点震惊。我要是那样肯定精神恍惚了。我绝不可能学得会新台词。不。而且我想象保罗当时根本没睡。他可能还穿着同一条内裤，因为他们的包丢了。你知道的，现在他觉得自己终于到达终点线了，结果他们又扔给他这样一个全新的任务。好吧，保罗发来了
few more clips about his experience just being on set. They're so delightful. We're going to sprinkle those in throughout the episode. All right. Fast fact number three, Angela. Mm hmm. I'm titling this. Am I the inspiration for this episode? I'm sorry. What were you a chair model? No. But in season one of the show, I wanted a new chair. He did. At reception. And I had to lobby for it. So I'm sure I'm not the inspiration for this episode. But in season one, they gave me a chair at reception without arms. It was an armless chair. And I really, really wanted a chair with arms. And so I attempted to try to sort of move the chairs or find a chair maybe that hadn't been claimed or used. It wasn't working. And
另外几个关于他在片场体验的片段。它们太可爱了。我们会在这一集的各个地方穿插播放这些片段。好的，速记事实三，安吉拉。嗯哼。我给这一段起的名字是。我是这一集的灵感来源吗？不好意思。你以前是个椅模吗？没有。但在本剧的第一季中，我想要一把新椅子。他确实想要。在前台。我不得不为此四处游说。所以我确信我不是这一集的灵感来源。但在第一季中，他们给了我一把没有扶手的椅子。那是一把无扶手的椅子。我真的非常非常想要一把带扶手的椅子。所以我试图去挪动椅子，或者找一把可能还没有人认领或使用的椅子。根本没用，而且
big shout out to our set dresser, Steve Rothstein, because he is one of the guys who headed up the team that picked out all our furniture on the office. And he got me a chair with arms. Oh, lady. And I was so excited. Well, I have a chair story for you. I've been holding on to this. I'm going to go ahead and tell you now. The chair I'm sitting in right now. Ready? I'm going to pan down. Do you see this chair? I do. It's a blue chair with mesh. Do you recognize it? I don't recognize it, but it has no arms. Phil Shea gave me this chair. It was a leftover chair from work bus. Oh my gosh, you've been sitting in a work bus chair this whole time for a year in my closet. I have been sitting in my work bus
隆重感谢我们的布景师史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦，因为他是负责挑选我们在《办公室》里所有家具的团队负责人之一。他给我弄到了一把带扶手的椅子。哦，天哪。我有一个关于椅子的故事要告诉你。我一直憋到现在。我现在就要告诉你。我屁股底下现在坐的这把椅子。准备好了吗？我要把镜头往下摇。你看到这把椅子了吗？我看到了。这是一把带网眼的蓝色椅子。你认得它吗？我不认得它，但它没有扶手。菲尔·谢伊给了我这把椅子。这是《工作巴士》那集剩下来的椅子。天哪，你这一整年、在我的衣帽间里一直坐在《工作巴士》的椅子上？我一直坐在我的《工作巴士》
chair and I was going to save it for work bus, but we're having all this chair talk. I couldn't hold it in anymore. Well, I just have to say this is why our show is so great because getting a chair is a very relatable big deal moment when you are in an office job or any job, your chair, you sit in it all day and they created this amazing, wonderful storyline out of it. Yes. And thank you, Phil Shea, because I had gotten a desk, you know, I had in the corner of my guest room, a little desk where I would sit and do work and I didn't have a proper desk chair. I was using one of the kitchen chairs and I was sort of talking about it
椅子上，我本来打算把它留到《工作巴士》那一集再说的，但我们一直在聊椅子。我实在憋不住了。好吧，我只想说这就是我们的节目这么棒的原因，因为当你做着办公室工作或任何工作时，能得到一把椅子是一件非常能引起共鸣的大事。整天都得坐在椅子上，他们竟然能从中创造出如此惊人、美妙的故事情节。是的。谢谢你，菲尔·谢伊，因为我当时在客房的角落里弄了一个小书桌，我会在那里坐着办公，但我没有一张合适的办公椅。我当时用的是厨房里的椅子，我有点在片场
on set and Phil Shea was like, Angie, I have some extra chairs from work bus. Do you want one? I was like, yes. This is making me happy. I know. We all have a chair story. And I have been sitting in it for a year with you and haven't told you because I was going to try to work it in a work bus. But there you go. Let's take a break and when we get back, we'll get into it. All right. We are back. We open on a gym and Pam talking head. They are standing outside of the Dunder Mifflin office and they are explaining that due to some renovations in the building, all of their parking spots are being taken up and they have to park in a
随口提到了这件事，菲尔·谢伊就说，安吉，我这里有一些《工作巴士》的多余椅子。你想要一把吗？我说，太好了。这让我太开心了。我知道。我们每个人都有一个关于椅子的故事。我和你一起坐在上面坐了一整年却一直没告诉你，因为我本来想在《工作巴士》那一集里顺便提一下。但就是这样。我们休息一下，等我们回来后，就开始进入正题吧。好的。我们回来了。镜头从一个健身房和帕姆的访谈镜头开始。他们站在邓德米夫林办公室外面，解释说由于大楼里的一些翻修工程，他们所有的停车位都被占用了，他们必须把车停在
satellite lot and walk to work. They're being really positive about it, though. Yeah, they saw a junkyard dog eating, you know, some of a chicken. Yeah, eating the bones of a rotisserie chicken, Angela, which was based on a real story. Yeah, it was. There was a junkyard next to our real office building and there was a junkyard dog who they would throw like old rotisserie chicken bones to. We've talked about this junkyard in the dog. We got very invested in this dog's life that lived over there. We did. And it made it into an episode. So then we have Oscar and Andy, who are less positive. And then there's Kevin, who is just downright angry. Kevin is going to have a breakdown over the satellite parking lot.
卫星停车场然后步行去上班。不过他们对此态度真的很积极。是的，他们看到一只垃圾场恶犬在吃，你知道的，一只烤鸡的一部分。是的，在吃一只烤鸡的骨头，安吉拉，这是根据真实故事改编的。是的，确实如此。我们真实的办公室大楼旁边有一个垃圾场，那里有一只垃圾场恶犬，大家会把吃剩的烤鸡骨头扔给它。我们聊过这个垃圾场和这只狗。我们对这只住在隔壁的狗的生活投入了极大的关注。我们确实如此。而且它还被写进了一集里。然后是奥斯卡和安迪，他们就没那么积极了。接着是凯文，他简直气坏了。凯文快要因卫星停车场而崩溃了。
Yeah. Well, Andy says he's so bummed because he lost a penny out of his penny loafers. Yeah. Jenna, I don't understand penny loafers, so I looked him up. Oh, you could have asked me, I wore penny loafers all through high school as part of my school uniform. Okay, well, why did you put a penny in your penny loafer? I don't know because there was a slot there for it. Okay, well, I'll tell you, I'll tell you why. Oh, well, you have put me in my place. I clearly don't know about penny loafers. You told me I could have asked you. Well, you're not answering my question. Why a penny in your loafers? So according to the internet, back in the 1930s, the pay phone in the phone booth cost two cents. The new
是的。好吧，安吉拉说他太沮丧了，因为他从乐福鞋上掉了一枚便士。是的，珍娜，我不懂什么是乐福鞋，所以我查了一下。哦，你本来可以问我啊，我整个高中都穿着乐福鞋，作为校服的一部分。好吧，那你为什么要在乐福鞋里塞一枚便士呢？我不知道，因为鞋上本来就有一个插槽。好吧，那我告诉你，我来告诉你为什么。哦，好吧，你可真是把我问住了。我显然对乐福鞋一无所知。你刚才还说我可以问你呢。好吧，你根本没回答我的问题。为什么要在乐福鞋里塞便士？所以根据互联网的说法，早在20世纪30年代，电话亭里的公用电话要两美分。新的
loafer design allowed just enough space for a penny in each shoe, equaling the cost of an emergency phone call. Thus, the penny and the loafer were united. But only men could make emergency phone calls. If you were a woman, so sorry, you don't even get a pocket to put your pennies in. Good luck, lady. You're just going to die on the street. But for the men, we have pockets, you can hide money in your shoes. Where else can we make life easy for you gentlemen? That took a turn. But point taken. So now the episode starts. And Jenna, it would have started with a deleted scene with Michael checking out of Shrewt Farms. Oh, what? Yeah. Oh, because he's been staying with Dwight? Yes. So there was an alternate
乐福鞋的设计让每只鞋里刚好能塞下一便士，正好够打一个紧急电话。就这样，便士和乐福鞋结合了。但只有男人才能打紧急电话。如果你是个女人，真遗憾，你连个装便士的口袋都没有。祝你好运，女士。你只能死在街头了。但对于男人们来说，我们有口袋，你可以把钱藏在鞋里。还有什么地方能让你们这些绅士的生活更轻松呢？话题转得有点硬。不过说得对。于是这集开始了。詹娜，本来应该以一个被删减的片段开场，迈克尔从史鲁特农场退房。哦，什么？是的。哦，因为他一直借住在德怀特家？是的。所以有一个备选
beginning where Michael is leaving the farm and he's like, it's moving day. You know, I've been here about a month. I let Jan have the condo and I'm moving out of Shrewt Farms. And as he's leaving Dwight goes hold up and hands him a bill. And Michael's like, wait, you were charging me this whole time? And Dwight was like, yeah. And then they have this funny back and forth about it. Oh my gosh, my mind is blown by the backstory that Michael lived with Dwight for a month. And it does sort of show why maybe now he's looking at the chair model like he is because he's a month past his breakup. And I don't know, maybe he's ready for something new. Yeah. Oh, can we see this deleted scene somewhere? Yes,
开场，迈克尔正离开农场，他说，今天是搬家日。你知道的，我在这里呆了一个月左右。我让简留下了公寓，我正搬出史鲁特农场。正当他离开时，德怀特说，等等，并递给他一张账单。迈克尔说，等等，这期间你一直在收我的钱？德怀特说，是的。然后他们为此进行了一场有趣的你来我往的对话。哦天哪，迈克尔和德怀特同住了一个月的背景故事让我大开眼界。这也某种程度上说明了为什么现在他看椅子模特儿的眼神会那样，因为他已经分手一个月了。而且我不知道，也许他准备好迎接新恋情了。是的。哦，我们能在哪里看到这个被删减的片段？是的，
it's on the DVDs. Amazing. So the scene they went with is this one in his office. He's looking through the catalog and really just gazing at this lady in this chair. Well, we had some fan mail about it. Carly D, Jenna A, Mariah K, and Charlotte S all wrote in to ask who played the chair model in the picture. The chair model was played by April Eden. She would go on to play Trish, aka Miss Pawnee in two episodes of Parks and Recreation. Well, I have a little background catch at a minute and nine seconds. There's a wonderful shot of the chair model, but the magazine is sitting on top of some message slips. Oh, and I zoomed in on the message slip. The message that was written down said, Andrea Ufer Uter, guys,
在DVD上有。太棒了。所以他们最终采用的片段是他办公室里的这一个。他翻看着目录，目光凝视着目录里的这位椅子模特。嗯，我们收到了一些关于这的粉丝来信。卡莉·D、詹娜·A、玛丽亚·K和夏洛特·S都写信来询问照片里扮演椅子模特的是谁。椅子模特由April Eden扮演。她后来在《公园与游憩》的两集中扮演了Trish，也就是Pawnee小姐。嗯，我在一分零九秒发现了一个小彩蛋。有一个椅子模特的美妙镜头，但杂志正压在一些留言条上面。哦，我放大看了留言条。上面写的内容是：安德丽亚·乌费尔·乌特，伙计们，
I don't know, I couldn't make it out from Dunder Louisville called and asked Michael to please call as soon as he returns and the number was 307-555-4438. So I called it. Well, that's a fake number. Well, yeah, it rang fast busy, but I wasn't sure. So I called it. No, you know that thing where in movies, they always start phone numbers with 555 because nobody has that as a prefix. Jenna, I know that, but we've had a phone number and it ended up being a sex hotline. So I decided to do my due diligence. It is a phony baloney number, but the area code 307 is a Wyoming area code, but there is no Louisville in Wyoming. There you have it. Boom! Everything you needed to know about this message slip next to the catalog. Angela, I admire you. I do. I
我不知道，路易斯维尔的邓德打电话来，让迈克尔一回来就回个电话，号码是307-555-4438。所以我打了过去。好吧，那是个假号码。好吧，是的，电话很快就占线了，但我不确定。所以我打了过去。不，你知道电影里的那种套路吗，电话号码总是以555开头，因为没有人会用这个做前缀。詹娜，我知道，但我们曾用过一个电话号码，结果它变成了一条色情热线。所以我决定尽到我的职责。这确实是个假号码，但307是怀俄明州的区号，而怀俄明州没有路易斯维尔。事情就是这样。砰！关于目录旁这张留言条，你需要知道的一切都在这了。安吉拉，我很佩服你。我是说真的。
really love that detail. Pam just needs Michael to pick a chair so that she can get his chair. But he is now obsessed with the chair model and Pam is very sad. But then Michael has a talking head where he says he really likes being single because he can start off each day with a sense of possibility. And this was my favorite part when this talking head takes a turn. He says, and each day becomes more desperate and desperate situations yield the quickest results. Which is kind of true. It is true. There was an alt talking head here that was pretty amazing. Jenna, you know the nursery rhyme where it's like Pam and Jim sitting in a tree, K-I-S-S-I-N-G. You know that one? Yes. So he has sort of used this nursery rhyme as a template for how to find your
我真的很喜欢这个细节。潘只是需要迈克尔选一把椅子，这样她就能得到他的椅子。但他现在迷上了椅子模特，潘非常伤心。但接着迈克尔有一个单人访谈，他说他真的很喜欢单身，因为他可以用一种无限可能的感觉开始每一天。而当这个单人访谈发生反转时，这是我最喜欢的部分。他说，每一天都变得更加绝望，而绝望的境地会产生最快的成果。这倒也有点道理。确实如此。这里原本有一个很棒的备选单人访谈。詹娜，你知道那个童谣吗，就是潘和吉姆坐在树上，K-I-S-S-I-N-G。你知道那个吗？是的。所以他有点把这个童谣当作模板，用来寻找
perfect match. And Sam, can you play it? Love, marriage, baby carriage. Those have been my goals ever since I heard that song. Jan and I had love. We did not have marriage. We did have a baby carriage, which I got her for bringing groceries home after she got a DUI. Oh my God. It's just so messed up. And I have to say, Jenna, in the scene with you when he says, remember after my dinner party when I said that I was swearing off women, the way you said, I definitely remember your dinner party was so good. You just crushed it. I love doing that scene with Steve. I remembered when I was watching it, how much we were laughing. It was just so fun. That was a good memory. It's a very subtle like reminder to to the audience what just came before this. Yeah. Okay. Well,
完美的另一半。萨姆，你能放一下吗？爱情，婚姻，婴儿车。自从我听到那首歌以来，这些就一直是我的目标。简和我曾有过爱情。我们没有婚姻。我们的确有过一辆婴儿车，那是我在她因酒驾回家后帮她拿杂货时送给她的。哦天哪。这简直太糟糕了。我不得不说，詹娜，在和你对戏的那个场子里，当他说，还记得我的晚宴派对之后我说我要跟女人绝交吗，你说的那个“我绝对记得你的晚宴派对”太棒了。你简直绝了。我很喜欢和史蒂夫拍那场戏。我在看的时候想起了我们当时笑得有多开心。那真是一个美好的回忆。这是一个非常微妙的提醒，提醒观众刚才发生了什么。好吧，
now Jenna, we have a Creed talking head that is phenomenal. It is phenomenal. He says, when Pam gets Michael's old chair, he gets Pam's old chair, which will bring him to two chairs. Only one more to go. Why does he need so many chairs? You're not the only person who's wondering. We got a lot of mail about it. So I texted Creed. Oh no. And he had a lot of answers for why he needed three chairs. And I'm going to share them all. Wait, wait, is this sort of like Creed the actor giving Creed the character backstory? Yes. Oh, I love it. All right. Option number one, he was growing weed in the ceiling. It was the same place where Angela threw her cat. Now he had access through a crawl space outside, but he needed to get in there at night by his desk. So after finally getting
现在詹娜，我们有一个克里德的单人访谈，简直绝了。太绝了。他说，当潘得到迈克尔的旧椅子时，他得到了潘的旧椅子，这将使他拥有两椅子。只差一把就凑齐了。为什么他需要那么多椅子？不只你一个人在纳闷。我们收到了很多关于这的信。所以我给克里德发了短信。哦不。关于他为什么需要三把椅子，他给出了很多答案。我打算把它们全部分享出来。等等，等等，这有点像演员克里德在给角色克里德补充背景故事吗？是的。哦，我喜欢。好的，第一种选择，他在天花板上种大麻。那地方和安吉拉扔猫的地方是同一个。现在他可以通过外面的狭小通道进去，但他需要在晚上从他的办公桌爬进去。所以经过一番努力终于弄到了
his three chairs and climbing into the ceiling, they collapsed one night and he was stranded in the ceiling. He wants you to know that's the whole thing that could have happened. Creed, what the hell are you talking about? You're going to stack three office chairs? I think all three of them had wheels. Yeah. Well, here's option number two. He said Creed stole many things from the office and he needed the extra chairs for a set because he was selling it to a competitive paper company. That I believe. Yes. I believe Creed had many side hustles. Well, here's his final answer. After perfecting his cartwheel, he wanted to use the three chairs as part of an obstacle course to really challenge himself. Well, that could have been very true. Oh, Creed, you're so fun. Thank you
他的三把椅子并爬进天花板后，有一天它们塌了，他被困在了天花板里。他想让你知道，这整件事都是可能发生的。克里德，你到底在胡说八道些什么？你要叠三把办公椅？我猜这三把都有轮子吧。好吧，这是第二种选择。他说克里德从办公室偷了很多东西，他需要额外的椅子来布置场景，因为他要把它卖给一家竞争对手的纸业公司。这个我信。是的。我相信克里德有很多副业。好吧，这是他的最终答案。在精通了侧手翻之后，他想用这三把椅子作为障碍训练的一部分来真正挑战自己。好吧，这倒很有可能是真的。哦，克里德，你太有趣了。谢谢你
for humoring us time and time again. Well, Michael tells everyone in the bullpen, get out your catalogs, open them to page 85 and take a look at the woman in the catalog. Yeah, use that as a template for who you're going to set me up with. Jenna, this was an announcement. He came out of his office to address his employees. Could you imagine working with a boss that made a huge announcement about how you should go about setting him up? No, later he says if you don't provide him a name by the end of the hour, you're going to be fired. We'll get there. But it's crazy. So now here's what I noticed. We all do get out these catalogs and we start opening up to page 85. And I remember these catalogs, Angela. Do you remember them? Yes. So we got mail about this to Mariah,
一次又一次地陪我们胡闹。好吧，迈克尔告诉办公区里的所有人，拿出你们的目录，翻到第85页，看一看目录里的那个女人。是的，把她当作模板，看看你们要给我介绍谁。詹娜，这是一个重大宣布。他从办公室出来向员工讲话。你能想象和一个老板一起工作，他会大肆宣布你应该如何帮他介绍对象吗？不，后来他说如果你在一小时内不提供一个名字，你就会被解雇。我们等会儿会讲到那。但太疯狂了。所以现在我注意到的是。我们真的都拿出了这些目录，开始翻到第85页。我记得这些目录，安吉拉。你还记得吗？是的。所以我们收到了关于这个的信，玛丽亚、
Charlotte and Christina all wanted to know, did the props department have to make an entire magazine just for these scenes with the catalog? No. So what they did was they had like an actual, I don't remember what it was, Angela. Do you, I think it was staples or office depot or something? And they glued a new cover on it. Yes. So it was like a Dunder Mifflin cover. Yeah. And then on the inside on page 85, they glued this two pages so that when we opened it up, yeah, we could show those two pages. But the rest of it was an actual office catalog. That's right. And they just had to print basically the cover and then the two insert pages that we would all turn to. Right. Jenna, you might notice there's not a lot of reaction shots of me in this because my belly
夏洛特和克里斯蒂娜都想知道，道具部门是不是真的为了这些目录的场景专门做了一整本杂志？不是的。所以他们做的是，他们拿了一本实际的，我不记得是什么了，安吉拉。你记得吗，我猜是史泰博或者欧迪办公之类的？然后他们在上面粘了一个新封面。是的。所以它看起来就像一个邓德米夫林的封面。是的，然后在第85页的内页里，他们把这两页粘在了一起，这样当我们翻开它时，是的，我们就可以展示这两页。但其余部分实际上一本办公目录。没错。他们基本上只需要打印封面，然后打印我们都会翻到的那两页插页。没错。詹娜，你可能会注意到里面没有很多我的特写镜头，因为我的肚子
was so big. I'm peak preggers here. That is why I'm not anyone that walked in, you know, like from the satellite parking lot. So Jenna, I don't know if you remember, but this week on our set, Chris Hastings, our NBC set photographer was there and he took a picture of me at my desk. I'm completely out of character and I'm pointing at my belly. Look, Jenna, here it is. Oh my God, you're huge. I know. Anyway, I'll put that in stories. But yeah, it was getting really hard to hide my belly. Well, there were enough shots of you, Angela. And I noticed that they were all very close up. They're like shoulders and up. But it's enough for me to notice that you were wearing a blouse with tiny keys on it. Little like skeleton keys.
太大了。我正处在孕期顶峰。这就是为什么我不是从卫星停车场走进来的任何人。所以詹娜，我不知道你是否记得，但本周在我们的片场，NBC的片场摄影师克里斯·海斯汀斯也在那里，他在我的办公桌旁给我拍了张照片。我完全脱离了角色，正指着我的肚子。看，詹娜，就是这张。哦天哪，你好大。我知道。不管怎样，我会把它发到快讯里。不过是的，要藏住我的肚子真的变得越来越难了。好吧，关于你的镜头已经够多了，安吉拉。我注意到它们都是非常近的特写。都是肩膀以上的镜头。但这也足够让我注意到你穿着一件印有小钥匙图案的上衣。有点像那种老式钥匙。
What was it? Lady, look at this picture. It's not a blouse. It's a freaking dress. It was a whole dress of it. It was a turtleneck dress. I mean, it looked like a moomoo. It was very comfortable. But we were starting to struggle with what could fit me over my belly and look like business attire of someone who was not pregnant. Yeah. I have a question for you. What is it? At three minutes, 35 seconds, you'll notice that Kevin and Michael are sitting on the sofa by front reception. Michael's wanting Kevin to set him up. He's asking him about Stacy. Do you know why they're sitting on the sofa and why Michael isn't in accounting talking to Kevin? Well, I know that Kevin's feet are in a foot bath. Is that why though? Yes, Jenna,
那是什么？女士，看看这张照片。这不是上衣。这特么是一条裙子。整条裙子都是这种图案。这是一条高领裙。我的意思是，它看起来像一件宽松长衫。穿着非常舒服。但我们开始为穿什么才能包住我的肚子，同时又看起来像一个非孕妇的商务着装而苦恼。是的。我有个问题要问你。什么问题？在三分35秒时，你会注意到凯文和迈克尔坐在前台旁边的沙发上。迈克尔想让凯文给他介绍对象。他正在向凯文打听斯黛西。你知道他们为什么坐在沙发上，而迈克尔为什么不去会计部和凯文谈吗？好吧，我知道凯文的脚在泡脚盆里。是因为这个吗？是的，詹娜，
there's a whole deleted scene where you're trying to answer the phone. But Kevin's foot bath, it's so loud. It sounds like a ginormous hot tub, but it's a little foot bath. So for the majority of this episode, Kevin is sitting there next to front reception. Yes, he is soaking his feet in his foot bath that he bought himself for the Christmas party episode, that very first episode. And it's such a wonderful callback. But since they cut that scene at reception, you can't even really see it. I tried to even find a time code where you could see the foot bath and you can't. You can't. You can see just like Kevin's pants are hiked up. You're like, why are they hiked up? Yeah. Why am I seeing Kevin's bare ankles? But it's because they're resting in a foot
有一个被删减的片段，你当时正试图接电话。但凯文的泡脚盆声音太大了。听起来像个巨大的热水浴缸，但它其实是个小泡脚盆。所以在这一集的大部分时间里，凯文都坐在前台旁边。是的，他正把脚泡在他在圣诞派对那一集，也就是第一集里自己买的泡脚盆里。这是一个非常精彩的呼应。但由于他们剪掉了前台的那场戏，你甚至根本看不见它。我甚至试图找到一个能看到泡脚盆的时间码，但你找不到。就是看不到。你只能看到凯文的裤腿卷起来了。你会想，它们为什么卷起来？是的。为什么我能看到凯文的光脚踝？但那是因为它们的脚正放在泡
bath and that's in the deleted scenes. Well, now Michael's going to walk around the office. He's going to try to make pleas to various people in the office to see if they have any single friends that they can set him up with, which leads to a very funny runner with Phyllis about her friend, Sandy. Phyllis is so good in this scene. So good. And the way Steve fires off his questions about Sandy. I mean, Phyllis says, look, she's gorgeous with a feisty personality. And Michael's like, so wait, Jolly or Sassy? Right. And Phyllis is like, no. And he's like, well, what does she do for a living? And Phyllis is like, she's a professional softball player. Michael's like, catch her or infield. And she's like, I don't know. Oh, and then he asked her if she could fit in a rowboat
脚盆里，这在被删减的片段里。好吧，现在迈克尔要在办公室里走动了。他要试着向办公室里的各种人恳求，看他们是否有单身朋友可以介绍给他，这导致了一段非常搞笑的关于菲利丝和她的朋友桑迪的情节。菲利丝在这场戏里太棒了。太棒了。还有史蒂夫抛出关于桑迪的问题的方式。我的意思是，菲利丝说，听着，她身材火辣，性格泼辣。而迈克尔却说，等等，是开朗还是刻薄？对。菲利丝说，不是。然后他说，那她以什么为生？菲利丝说，她是个职业垒球运动员。迈克尔说，是接球手还是内野手？她却说，我不知道。哦，然后他问她是否能坐进划艇里，
in a standard size rowboat. And Phyllis gets so angry with him. She's like, fine, no, Michael. No, she can't fit in a rowboat. It's really amazing writing. Michael really loses it now, Angela. And he gives this impassioned speech where he says he wants to play ball with his kids before he's too old. But first, he needs to get laid. And that means he needs to be in love. Oh, that kind of made me love Michael for saying that he just wants the picket fence and the kids and the two car garage. And he he just Michael is one of these people and I and anyone out there that's had children, you know how you have one of your kids who just wants a family? Yes. And Michael was that kid since he was a little boy. All he wanted was a family. I mean, if you and not
标准大小的划艇里。菲利丝气得火冒三丈。她说，行了，不，迈克尔。不，她坐不进划艇。这段台词写得真是绝了。安吉拉，迈克尔现在真的失控了。他发表了一段充满激情的演讲，说他想在自己太老之前和孩子们一起打球。但首先，他需要破处。这意味着他需要恋爱。哦，这让我有点爱上迈克尔了，因为他说他只想要白围栏、孩子和两车库。他他只是迈克尔就是这种人，而且如果有任何育有子女的观众，你们就会知道你总会有一个只想组建家庭的孩子。是的。而迈克尔从小到大就是那个孩子。他想要的就是一个家庭。我的意思是，如果你不
to be a downer, but I don't think Michael had a great family experience as a child. And he's still longing for it as an adult. Of course. That's like part of his whole driving force. Yeah. Is to find family, whether it be at work or with a partner, he wants family. Yes. Well, this is now Angela, where Michael says, everybody, I want you to give me the name of someone that he can go on a date with within the hour or they're fired. And Dwight is going to hand out index cards that he's already written prompts for. Did you see that? Yeah, he's ready. He's ready. Well, listen, let's take a break. And when we come back, we will find out how this goes. Guess what? Not well, should maybe, but short. That's right.
想扫兴的话，我不认为迈克尔在童年时有过很好的家庭体验。而他作为一个成年人，依然在渴望这个。当然。这是他整个人行动力的一部分。是的。就是寻找家庭，无论是在工作中还是与伴侣在一起，他都想要家庭。是的。好吧，安吉拉，这就是迈克尔说的那一幕，大家，我要你们在一小时内给我一个可以跟他约会的人的名字，否则你们就被开除了。而德怀特则要分发他已经写好提示的索引卡。你看到了吗？是的，他准备好了。他已经准备好了。好吧，听着，我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会看看事情进展得如何。你猜怎么着？不太顺利，也许吧，但话说回来。就是这样。
Well, we're back. We're in Michael's office. Andy and Kevin are really making a passionate plea to Michael to please do something about these parking spots that the construction guys are blocking. Michael says, you know what, he's gotten assigned parking spots. So not really affecting him. And there is a couplet of dialogue, Jenna, that just cracked me up seven minutes, four seconds. Michael says, wish I could, but I can't. Well, can but won't should maybe short. And Kevin's like, Michael, please. And then Michael says, what part of short don't you understand, Kevin? What part of short don't you understand? They're on their own. He's not going to help them. No, but he does give them permission to fix the problem themselves. Yeah, right. He thinks this
好吧，我们回来了。我们在迈克尔的办公室里。安迪和凯文正向迈克尔极力恳求，请他为建设工人们挡住的这些停车位做点什么。迈克尔说，你知道吗，他有指定的停车位。所以这对他没什么影响。詹娜，有一对台词让我笑得前仰后合，在七分零四秒。迈克尔说，想帮但帮不了。嗯，能帮但不愿帮，也许吧，长话短说。凯文说，迈克尔，求你了。然后迈克尔说，长话短说这四个字你哪里不懂，凯文？长话短说这四个字你哪里不懂？他们只能靠自己了。他不会帮他们的。不，但他确实允许他们自己去解决问题。是的，没错。他认为这
will be a good thing for them to figure this out. Right. An exercise. Meanwhile, in the break room, I don't even know what title to give this. Everyone is sitting trying to come up with a name to put on their card for Michael. We had a fan question from Stephanie, Emily, Laura, and Anne. When giving Michael names of single women, he should ask out, Jim writes down Pam's mom. I know, right? Was this an intentional foreshadowing or just a coincidence? Well, guys, spoiler alert. In future seasons, Michael is going to date Pam's mom. It was a very controversial storyline. We'll get to it. I think this was the first time the writers had ever even thought of this idea. And it was just a funny joke in the moment. But I have to believe
对他们来说会是个弄清状况的好机会。没错。一种锻炼。与此同时，在休息室里，我甚至不知道该给这集起个什么标题。每个人都坐着试图想出一个名字写在卡片上给迈克尔。我们收到了来自斯蒂芬妮、艾米丽、劳拉和安的粉丝提问。当给迈克尔提供单身女性的名字让他去约会时，吉姆写下了潘的妈妈。我懂，对吧？这是有意为之的伏笔还是纯属巧合？好吧，伙计们，剧透预警。在未来的剧季中，迈克尔将和潘的妈妈约会。这是一个非常有争议的剧情线。我们会讲到它的。我认为这是编剧们第一次萌生这个想法。当时它只是一个有趣的玩笑。但我必须相信
that it stayed in their brains. It planted a seed. Well, there's a deleted scene between Michael and Kelly, where Michael's like, Kelly, who are you going to set me up with? And she's like, well, I have a friend who's 23. And he's like, yeah. And she's like, oh, you know, I actually have the perfect group to set you up with my friend's parents who've gotten divorced. And Michael's like, ah, and he walks off disgusted. So there is sort of this running joke in this episode that didn't fully make it in that like Kelly is going to set Michael up with this whole older group of people. Right. The divorcee. I guess I'll say the writers at this time didn't know yet that they were going to write that storyline. But I think this was the beginning of something.
它留在了他们的脑海里。它埋下了一颗种子。好吧，迈克尔和凯莉之间有一段被删减的片段，迈克尔说，凯莉，你要给我介绍谁？她说，嗯，我有一个23岁的朋友。他说，好吧。她说，哦，你知道，我实际上有一个完美的人选要介绍给你，我朋友的父母离婚了。迈克尔说，啊，然后他厌恶地走开了。所以这一集里其实有一个贯穿始终的玩笑，并没有完全放进去，那就是凯莉要给迈克尔介绍一整群年纪更大的人。没错。离异人士。我想我会说当时的编剧们还不知道他们要写那条剧情线。但我认为这是某个事情的开始。
It's the group mind, lady. There it is in action. I love that Michael calls Wendy. It's so funny. Do you know who the voice of Wendy was? We got a lot of mail about it. And I wrote to Kent Sabornak, and he did not remember who we cast. But one of the finalists for the role was Lindsay Broad, who ends up playing an arc on the show. Yeah. Now, I don't think she got the role. I really listened to the voice and I think it was someone else. So I don't have the answer. But I thought it was very interesting that Lindsay had auditioned for just this voice role. Right. Well, you know who's on the case. Who's always on the case? Dwight. Dwight. He's on the case. He's going to find Michael, the chair model. Yeah. And he says, I will find her and I will
这是集体意识，女士。它正在起作用。我喜欢迈克尔给温迪打电话。太搞笑了。你知道温迪的声音是谁配的吗？我们收到了很多关于这的邮件。我写信给肯特·萨博纳克，他不记得我们试镜了谁。但该角色的决赛选手之一是琳赛·布劳德，她最后在剧中有一个客串单元。是的。现在，我不认为她得到了这个角色。我仔细听了那个声音，觉得是别人。所以我没有答案。但我认为很有趣的是，琳赛只为这个声音角色试镜。对。好吧，你知道谁在查案。谁总是在查案？德怀特。德怀特。他在查案。他要找到迈克尔的椅子模特。是的。他说，我会找到她，我会
bring her to you. And as God is my witness, she shall bear your fruit. This is such good writing, in my opinion, that we set up that Dwight is going to go on this quest. And the quest literally lasts one scene. Like, I think the expectation in writing is that we're now going to watch Dwight go on a search for the chair model. But then he sums it all up in one talking head. Yeah, he basically only had to make two phone calls. So the furniture company put him in touch with the advertising agency who put him in touch with the photographer who put him in touch with the modeling agency. And the modeling agency told him that she died in a car accident. Case closed. Case closed. Investigation over. And by the way, he's super proud of his investigation.
带她来见你。天地良心，她将为你开花结果。依我看，这剧本写得太好了，我们铺垫了德怀特要去寻找她。而这个寻找过程实际上只持续了一个场景。我的意思是，剧本的预期可能是我们要看德怀特去寻找椅子模特。但接着他用一段独白就把这一切总结了。对，他基本上只需要打两个电话。所以家具公司让他联系了广告公司，广告公司让他联系了摄影师，摄影师让他联系了模特公司。然后模特公司告诉他，她在车祸中丧生了。结案。结案。调查结束。顺便说一句，他为自己的调查感到非常自豪。
And it's not really landing on him that this is horrible news. Michael takes the news really hard. He has to sit down in Dwight's chair. Yeah. And Jim says, Michael, you didn't even know her. Gasp. Even Pam shakes her head at Jim. Like Jim, not now. Michael's like, try not to be so hurtful, Jim. Dwight's like, how dare you? And one of my favorite lines of this whole episode is coming up. What is it? Pam says, okay, Michael, you know what? I might have someone for you. And Michael says, oh, really? What's her name? Burger King. Yeah, that made me laugh all out too. Made me laugh so hard. Pam, for whatever reason, decides to give Michael the phone number of her landlady. Margaret. She says she's really nice. And I think you might get along.
而且他并没有真正意识到这是个可怕的消息。迈克尔对这个消息打击很大。他不得不坐在德怀特的椅子上。是的。吉姆说，迈克尔，你甚至都不认识她。天呐。甚至连帕姆都对吉姆摇了摇头。就像吉姆，现在别这样。迈克尔说，尽量别那么伤人，吉姆。德怀特说，你怎么敢！而整集中我最喜欢的台词之一就要来了。是什么？帕姆说，好吧，迈克尔，你知道吗？我可能有个适合你的人选。迈克尔说，哦，真的吗？她叫什么名字？汉堡王。是的，这也把我逗得哈哈大笑。把我笑得不行。帕姆无论出于什么原因，决定把她房东的电话号码给迈克尔。玛格丽特。她说她人真的很好。我想你们可能会合得来。
I mean, Michael's jazzed. He's excited. He starts brushing his teeth in the kitchen sink. Why can't he do that in the men's room? Well, don't worry, Angela, he's not going to spit it out. He swallows it. Did you notice that? Yes. So disgusting. Also, electric toothbrush. Also, remember when we were wondering in local ad, does he have a toothbrush in the office? He does. So now the five families are going to be assembled. Andy and Kevin are doing it. Kevin has a talking head where he breaks down the five families, how they rarely ever meet. Yeah. And they have this great footage of each member of the five families. It's pretty amazing. I have two little fun facts from this. Okay. So now when they show WB Jones, they kind of show a clip of what looks like a
我是说，迈克尔兴奋极了。他很激动。他开始在厨房水槽刷牙。他为什么不在男洗手间刷？好吧，别担心，安吉拉，他不会吐出来的。他把它吞下去了。你注意到了吗？是的。太恶心了。还有，电动牙刷。还有，还记得我们在拍《本地广告》时纳闷过，他办公室里有牙刷吗？他确实有。现在，五大家族要聚齐了。安迪和凯文正在做这件事。凯文有一段独白，剖析了五大家族，他们平时几乎从不碰面。是的。他们有五大家族每个成员的精彩录像。这太棒了。我从中得到了两个有趣的小冷知识。好的。现在当他们展示W·B·琼斯时，他们剪辑了一个片段，看起来像是
commercial that he's in where he's selling his air conditioners, right? Right. There's a 1-800 number in that commercial on the screen. Did you call it? I didn't need to call it because it's the exact same number that was on the flyer in women's appreciation, which we know is a sex hotline. Why do we keep recycling this number? I think we must have bought this number because after this episode came out, they put an outgoing message for WB Jones. So if you called it, you got that message. Yeah, we must have owned it for a bit and we clearly don't own it anymore. We really don't. Well, the other fun fact I have about this little montage is that at 10 minutes 55 seconds, we see a photo of cool guy Paul sitting on a motorcycle and there's a very
他出演的广告，他在广告里卖空调，对吧？对。那个广告的屏幕上有一个1-800的电话号码。你打了吗？我不需要打，因为这跟我们在《女性赞赏日》传单上看到的号码完全一样，我们知道那是一个色情热线。为什么我们一直在循环使用这个号码？我想我们肯定是买了这个号码，因为在这集播出后，他们为W·B·琼斯设置了一条离职留言。所以如果你打过去，你就会听到那条留言。是的，我们肯定买断了一阵子，而且我们现在显然不拥有它了。真的没有了。好吧，关于这个小蒙太奇，我另一个有趣的小冷知识是，在10分55秒时，我们看到了一张酷哥保罗坐在摩托车上的照片，这里有一个非常
interesting story here. Sam, will you play this clip from Paul? Hey, so a quick story about that motorcycle picture because a lot of people ask me, is that your motorcycle? And no, it's actually, we were shooting the scenes and we were supposed to shoot somewhere on some guy's house in a back deck overlooking the ocean, but it got late in the day and they didn't want to move the whole crew and the cameras and the lighting and that all that stuff. So right behind the lot where they shoot all the scenes where the office is, is a residential neighborhood. So we went through the fence and it was some guy's house and we just set up on the front lawn. I believe it was the motorcycle of one of the camera guys. He happens to ride motorcycles. So he brought his motorcycle
有趣的故事。山姆，你能放一下保罗的这段音频吗？嘿，关于那张摩托车照片有个简短的故事，因为很多人问我，那是你的摩托车吗？其实不是，我们当时正在拍戏，本打算在某人家的后甲板上拍，那里俯瞰着海洋，但天色已晚，他们不想搬动整个剧组、摄像机、灯光和所有那些东西。所以，就在他们拍摄办公室所有场景的那个地块后面，是一个住宅区。于是我们穿过篱笆，那是某个人的房子，我们就直接在前草坪上布置了。我相信那是其中一个摄像师的摩托车。他刚好骑摩托车。所以他把他的摩托车
around. I sat on it, we took a bunch of pictures and that just became the shot associated with cool guy Paul and it saved having to move everybody to another location and spend hours doing it. So people always ask me, is that your motorcycle? How'd you get the motorcycle? But nope, it was just a quick shot of one of the crew members' motorcycles. Well, Jenna, I reached out to Kenneth Paul who did my makeup on the show because he rode a Harley, right? To set. Every day to work and I sent him the picture and I said, Kenneth Paul, is this your motorcycle? And he said, no, Angela, that's not a Harley. It's not mine. So we don't know whose motorcycle it was, but I think that was Tom Melby's yard. Oh, for sure. When I heard Paul's clip and he said we went to
骑了过来。我坐在上面，拍了一堆照片，这就成了与酷哥保罗相关的镜头，省得把所有人搬到另一个地方还要花上几个小时。所以人们总是问我，那是你的摩托车吗？你怎么弄到摩托车的？但不是，这只是剧组人员摩托车的一个快照。好吧，詹娜，我联系了在剧组给我化过妆的肯尼斯·保罗，因为他骑着一辆哈雷，对吧？去片场。每天上班都骑，我把照片发给他，我说，肯尼斯·保罗，这是你的摩托车吗？他说，不，安吉拉，那不是哈雷。不是我的。所以我们不知道那是谁的摩托车，但我认为那是汤姆·梅尔比的院子。哦，肯定的。当我听到保罗的音频，他说我们穿过篱笆去了
some guy's yard through a fence, Tom Melby was our, I guess, general maintenance guy on the show. Mm-hmm. He was always fixing things when we went on vacations. He was the person who watered the plants and he lived right behind the set in a house. I loved the idea that cool guy Paul was originally gonna be filmed like in a big mansion with the ocean behind him. It definitely tracks, right? Yeah, but then they had to scramble and they're like, what else is cool? Ooh, a motorcycle. And I kind of love the motorcycle better, actually. I do too. So Jenna, at 11 minutes 30 seconds, it is time for Michael to go on his date. He's at the coffee shop. He's a little early, so he's gonna go ahead and get a cup of coffee. Oh, here's his order. Large hot chocolate with
某个人的院子，汤姆·梅尔比是我们的，我猜是剧组的总维修工。嗯。每次我们度假时他总是在修理东西。他是那个给植物浇水的人，而且他就住在片场后面的房子里。我太喜欢这个想法了，酷哥保罗原本要在海景豪宅里拍摄。这绝对说得通，对吧？是的，但后来他们不得不手忙脚乱地想，还有什么酷的东西？哦，摩托车。其实我反而更喜欢摩托车。我也是。所以詹娜，在11分30秒时，迈克尔该去约会了。他在咖啡店。他去得有点早，所以他打算先买杯咖啡。哦，这是他的点单：大杯热巧克力加
caramel and a shot of peppermint. He's gonna pay for it with his, did you notice, bejeweled wallet? No. Yeah. What? It's really subtle, but if you freeze at 11 minutes 26 seconds, Michael is paying for his coffee. Yeah. And his wallet has an outline of little bedazzled fuchsia gems. I am so curious why. Did Jan get bored and bedazzle everything in their whole condo one day? Perhaps. I looked at it so closely, there's no name on it. It's just an outline. I need to see that. Fascinating. Well, he's looking around and he's trying to figure out where's his date. He's wearing a rose on his lapel, right? Because that's how you'll know it's him. Could you imagine if Michael was in The Bachelor, that reality show?
焦糖和薄荷风味。他要用他的，你注意到了吗，镶钻钱包付款？没有。真的吗？什么？这真的很隐蔽，但如果你在11分26秒暂停，迈克尔正在为他的咖啡付钱。是的。他的钱包边缘镶嵌了一圈小小的紫红色宝石。我太好奇为什么了。詹娜是不是有一天无聊了，把他们整个公寓的所有东西都镶上了钻？也许吧。我仔细看了看，上面没有名字。只有一个轮廓。我得去看看。太迷人了。好吧，他环顾四周，试图找出他的约会对象在哪。他翻领上别着一朵玫瑰，对吧？因为那样你就能认出是他了。你能想象如果迈克尔去参加那个真人秀节目《黄金单身汉》会怎么样吗？
So crazy. That would be so good. I was thinking the other day, what would I be like on The Bachelor? Oh, God, you wouldn't do it. You'd say, oh, right. All these women have to kiss the same guy. F you, patriarchy. You wouldn't do it. But then I was sort of like daydreaming about me getting out of the limo in my joggers and a hoodie and just keeping it super real. I was like, dude, I'm getting out of the limo. How you're gonna see me most of the time after we have two kids. And if you love me now, you're gonna love me then. And I think we should start this way. That'd be my pitch. You literally said that with like a snarl in your lip. You're like, this is... I did. It's badass. It's a badass way to start a date. If you're getting out of a limo on my first
太疯狂了。那一定太棒了。我前几天还在想，如果我去参加《黄金单身汉》会是什么样？天呐，你才不会去呢。你会说，哦，对啊。所有这些女人都得亲同一个男人。去你的父权制。你才不会去呢。但后来我有点在白日做梦，梦见自己穿着慢跑裤和连帽衫从加长豪华轿车里走出来，表现得超级真实。我想，老兄，我要从加长车里出来了。这就是我们在有了两个孩子之后，你大部分时间看到我的样子。如果你现在爱我，你以后也会爱我。我觉得我们应该这样开始。这就是我的推销台词。你刚才说这话时，嘴唇上带着一丝狞笑。你就像，这是……我确实这样了。这很酷。这是开始约会的一种很酷的方式。如果你在我的第一次
date, you've already lost me. It's so true. If you want to dial up the doucheery, show up in your limo. Well, Michael sees a woman. It's such a funny line. He says, I'm looking for a woman in blue jeans and a black top with brown hair. And he goes, there she is. And the camera swings to a blonde. A tall blonde wearing a skirt, like a floral skirt with a top. Clearly not the description he was given. But he says, there she is. I give her a 10 for looks and a three for describing herself. Oh, he's so charmed. Okay, obviously, the woman in the dress is not his date, since she's dressed nothing as described. But then Pam's landlady walks in Margaret, wearing jeans and a black top. And Michael gets one look at her. He's clearly disappointed.
约会时从加长轿车里走出来，你已经失去我了。确实如此。如果你想把混蛋程度拉满，就坐着你的豪华轿车出现吧。好吧，迈克尔看到一个女人。这台词太搞笑了。他说，我在找一个穿牛仔裤、黑色上衣、留着棕色头发的女人。然后他说，她在那儿。镜头转向了一个金发女郎。一个高个金发女郎，穿着裙子，比如一条碎花裙配上上衣。显然跟他被告知的描述完全不符。但他说，她在那儿。外表我给十分，自我描述我给三分。哦，他太着迷了。好吧，很明显，穿裙子的女人不是他的约会对象，因为她的穿着跟描述的完全不沾边。但接着帕姆的房东玛格丽特走了进来，穿着牛仔裤和黑色上衣。迈克尔看了她一眼。他明显失望了。
And he tries to get out of it. Oh, it's so cringy. And she's really cute and like nice. Like, what is wrong with Michael? Michael has such a bad picker. Yes. Well, Pam's landlady was played by Brooke Dilman. She is an improv comedy actress. She starred in this sketch comedy show called Blue Collar TV. And by the way, she has voiced several characters on Bob's burger. She's amazing. She's just got the chops. Brooke is hilarious. I have just known her through improv circles over the years. And she's so funny. And you know, I know her role as Margaret was supposed to be understated. And I just wish you guys could see the comedy chops she has. I know you see it in her timing of the scene and all of that. But she is really, really funny. You know, a lot of times
他试图溜之大吉。哦，太令人尴尬了。而且她人真的很可爱也很友好。迈克尔到底怎么了？迈克尔的眼光太差了。是的。好吧，帕姆的房东由布鲁克·迪尔曼饰演。她是一名即兴喜剧演员。她主演过一档名为《蓝领电视》的小品喜剧秀。顺便说一句，她还为《开心汉堡店》中的几个角色配音。她太棒了。她很有喜剧功底。布鲁克非常搞笑。这些年来，我通过即兴表演圈认识了她。她太有趣了。你知道，我知道她扮演的玛格丽特本来应该是低调的。我只希望你们能看到她所具备的喜剧功底。我知道你们从她对场景时机的把握中能看出来。但她真的非常非常有趣。你知道，很多时候
it takes a great comedic performer to play restraint. Yeah. To have the patience to play the restraint. Yes. And to not try to overload the scene with their own bits. Yeah. And she does it perfectly. Incidentally, she graduated from the University of Missouri's theater program. Good ol' Mizzou. That was about 90 minutes away from the school that I went to in Kirksville, Missouri. I had to drive through Mizzou, Columbia, Missouri, to get to Kirksville. You and Brooke, Chris Croson. Exactly. I know. We're both two gals from theater schools in Missouri who landed on the office. Go Mo. The scene between Margaret and Michael is so cringy. Michael literally is like rubbing his forehead like he's in pain. He's like,
伟大的喜剧表演往往需要有所克制。是的。要有耐心去进行克制的表演。是的。而不是试图用自己的段子让场景超载。是的。她做得完美无瑕。顺便说一句，她毕业于密苏里大学戏剧系。老密苏里。那离我在密苏里州柯克斯维尔上学的学校大约有90分钟车程。我必须开车穿过密苏里州哥伦比亚市才能到达柯克斯维尔。你和布鲁克，克里斯·克罗森。正是。我懂。我们俩都是来自密苏里州戏剧学校、最后来到《办公室》的姑娘。密苏里加油。玛格丽特和迈克尔之间的场景太尴尬了。迈克尔简直就像在揉额头，好像痛苦一样。他说，
so you get the rent checks every month. And she's like, yeah. I mean, it's like, I know. He's like, and then what do you do with them? And she goes, are you really asking me what I do with the checks that people give me? And he's like, I'm just, I'm trying to make conversation. Okay. Oh, Michael. And he just talks about like, he goes, well, this is who I was dating before you and he shows the photo of Jan. And then he calls her by accident. It's just like layer of layer of cringy. And then he kind of starts opening up to Margaret about like how it's so hard to find someone. And he tells her, you know, thanks, this has been nice. It's like talking to the old lady on the bus. And Margaret's had it. She's like, you're rude. That was rude.
所以你每个月都能收到房租支票。她就说，对啊。我的意思是，这就像，我懂。他说，然后你拿它们怎么办？她说，你真的在问我怎么处理别人给我的支票吗？他说，我只是，我只是想找个话题聊天。好吧。哦，迈克尔。他只是谈论着，他说，嗯，这是在我之前跟你约会的人，然后他展示了简的照片。接着他一不小心叫错了她的名字。这就像是一层又一层的尴尬。然后他开始向玛格丽特敞开心扉，谈论找个人有多难。他告诉她，你知道，谢谢，这挺不错的。就像在公车上跟老太太聊天一样。玛格丽特受够了。她说，你真粗鲁。刚才那样很粗鲁。
Well, and then Michael says, well, now you've ruined it. Michael was such a jerk in this scene. Listen, if you had any sympathy for him after dinner party, it's evaporated after this scene. Yeah, we were very good at taking you on quite the roller coaster as your feelings for Michael are concerned on this show. But at this scene, I was like, you deserve Jan. You deserve to sleep on the bench at the foot of the bed. You're being such a turd. Exactly. It's very complicated. Well, now we go into this wonderful scene where Andy and Kevin are going to meet with the heads of the five families. Yeah. Make their plea. They're in what looks like to be some kind of conference room at the Scranton Business Park. I wanted to point out at 14 minutes, 12 seconds,
好吧，然后迈克尔说，好吧，现在你把它给毁了。迈克尔在这个场景里简直是个混蛋。听着，如果你在《晚宴派对》之后对还有所同情的话，在这个场景之后也烟消云散了。是的，当涉及到你对这部剧中迈克尔的看法时，我们非常擅长带你经历一趟过山车。但在这一幕，我心想，你活该拥有简。你活该睡在床尾的长凳上。你简直是个混蛋。确实如此。这很复杂。好吧，现在我们进入这个精彩的场景，安迪和凯文将与五大家族的头目会面。是的。陈述他们的诉求。他们在斯克兰顿商业园的一个类似会议室的地方。我想指出的是，在14分12秒时，
how nice the frickin TV is in this conference room. Yeah. It is a true big flat screen TV. Not like Michael's tiny one. Nothing like our crazy old tube TV that we roll in on a cart for our conference room scenes. Yeah. It's like a fancy big flat screen TV. Yeah. Imagine if Michael had seen it, he would have passed out. Well, we asked Paul about shooting this scene, and I loved what he had to say. Here it is. So being on set, it's sort of be careful what you wish for because I'm a huge fan of the show. I think they're super funny. And I remember the first time we were about to shoot, they say, okay, quiet on the set, cameras rolling, and I will never forget it. But Brian says, okay, nobody asked Paul and he looks
这个会议室里的电视有多棒。是的。这是一台真正的超大平板电视。不像迈克尔那台极小的电视。一点也不像我们为了会议室场景而用推车推进来的那种疯狂的旧显像管电视。是的。就像一台豪华的大平板电视。是的。想象一下，如果迈克尔看到它，他会昏过去的。好吧，我们问了保罗关于拍摄这个场景的感受，我非常喜欢他的话。就是这样。所以身处片场，有点像小心你许下的愿望，因为我是这部剧的超级粉丝。我觉得他们超级搞笑。我记得我们第一次要拍的时候，他们说，好了，片场安静，摄像机开拍，我永远不会忘记。但布莱恩说，好吧，没人问保罗，然后他看着
at me. And, you know, he was messing around, but it was so funny. And then the entire time we shot the scene, I had my lines to say, but we shot it about 20, 30 times. And every single time, Brian and Ed said different things. And I happened to think they're super funny. And it was very hard to keep straight face. I never knew it was going to come out of their mouths. They were making face to me trying to get me to laugh. And I just sit there and be dead serious. I don't want to be the guy to mess up the scene. So working with people who were literally comic geniuses in their delivery and their timing and having to sit there and being the new guy on set and trying to keep a straight face and not to mess up was a challenge. But such a life, a life experience and just so
我。你知道，他是在开玩笑，但太搞笑了。然后我们拍这个场景的全程，我有台词要说，但我们大概拍了20、30遍。每一次，布莱恩和爱德说的话都不一样。而我碰巧觉得他们超级搞笑。要保持面不改色太难了。我永远不知道他们嘴里会说出什么。他们对我做鬼脸，想逗我笑。而我只能坐在那里一脸严肃。我可不想成为那个把场景搞砸的人。所以跟这些在台词交付和时机把握上堪称喜剧天才的人合作，不得不坐在那里，作为片场的新人，努力保持面不改色不搞砸，真是一个挑战。但这是一段人生经历，做起来太有趣了。我很荣幸能成为《办公室》一小部分的一员。
funny to do. And I'm so honored to be a part of a small little part of the office. I love that Brian and Ed were trying to mess with them. We would do this. We would know when someone was going to break and we would have a little fun. We would. It's true. Well, Paul mentioned to us, you know, what it was like to get lines at the last minute, but he also talks to us about what it was like just being on the set and the lingo that they used. So we're shooting the scene over and over again. You know, we want to get it right. And sometimes the lines don't work, but the facial expressions are great. So one of the guys comes in and says, when this happens, I forget the word used, I want you to do this. And then he walked out
我喜欢布莱恩和爱德试图捉弄他的情景。我们会这样的。我们会知道什么时候有人会笑场，然后我们会找点乐子。我们会这么做的。确实如此。好吧，保罗向我们提到，你知道，最后一分钟才拿到台词是什么感觉，但他也跟我们谈了身处片场以及他们使用的行话是什么感觉。所以我们一遍又一遍地拍这个场景。你知道，我们想把它拍好。有时台词效果不好，但面部表情很棒。所以其中一个人走进来，当发生这种情况时，我忘了用的是哪个词，我想要你这样做。然后他走了出去
and I'm looking around like, uh, I have no idea what that means. So the camera guy behind me, he's like, you don't know what that means. I'm like, no, I've never done this before. He goes, okay, I'll tap you on the shoulder when you should say your line. So I was literally sitting there and something was going on. And I felt the camera guy who was shooting over my shoulder, tap me on the shoulder when to say my line. And it was just sort of indicative of the whole experience because everybody was so friendly and helpful and just wanted to get it done right. Um, except I think, uh, uh, Brian and Ed, who were just trying to make me laugh the whole time. Can I say, Angela, that when we got these audio clips from Paul, the thing that was so fun for
而我环顾四周，心想，呃，我完全不知道那是什么意思。所以我身后的摄像师说，你不知道那是什么意思吗？我说，不知道，我以前从来没做过这个。他说，好吧，当你该说台词时，我会拍拍你的肩膀。所以我真的坐在那里，正发生着某些事。我感觉到在我身后拍摄的摄像师拍了拍我的肩膀，提示我该说台词了。这简直是整个经历的缩影，因为每个人都那么友好、乐于助人，只想把事情做好。嗯，除了我想，呃，布莱恩和爱德，他们只是想让我全程笑场。我能说吗，安吉拉，当我们收到保罗的这些音频剪辑时，对我来说最有趣的事情是作为一个非演员在片场观察，因为这真的把我带回了我作为演员生涯中的所有那些时刻，你才刚刚开始在应变中学习。我在戏剧学校没学过任何这些东西。而且我甚至不知道还有没有什么其他方法可以学到它。你只是在当下那种情境中吸收它，但他发来的一个音频剪辑是我的最爱。
me was his observations as a non-actor being on a set because it really took me back to all of those moments in my career as an actor where you just started learning on the fly. I didn't learn any of this stuff in theater school. And I don't even know if there is any other way to learn it. You just kind of absorb it in the moment, but he sent in an audio clip that is my favorite. Me too. Because I struggled with this too. You and I have talked about this, but I don't think we've ever talked about it on the pod. So this is great. I love that he had the same, the same observation. Okay, we'll play it and then we'll talk about it. So this was a new experience for me. I kind of, it was my first time being really on the set and I'm sitting on my trailer going,
我也是。因为我也曾为此苦恼过。你和我谈过这个，但我想我们从来没在播客里谈过。所以这太棒了。我喜欢他也有同感。好吧，我们放一下然后我们来聊聊。所以这对我是全新的体验。我有点，这是我第一次真正待在片场，我坐在我的拖车里心想，
well, what do I do now? So I decided to get something to eat. I walk out and I'm like, where can I get some food? And they pointed me in the direction of where the breakfast was. And as I started walking, I heard someone in a headset go, cool guy, Paul's going to breakfast. And then I come back and I hear them go, cool guy, Paul's back in his trailer. Everywhere I went, someone's like, cool guy, Paul's in the bathroom, cool guy, Paul's in it. Like someone had to know where I was at all time. I thought it was really funny. They had to track me to make sure they knew where I was in case they needed me. So that was one super funny story from being on the set. Yeah, you guys, on film and television sets, there is a whole
那我现在该做什么？所以我决定去找点吃的。我走出去，心想，我在哪里可以弄到吃的？他们给我指了早餐的方向。当我开始走的时候，我听到对讲机里有人说，酷哥保罗去吃早餐了。然后我回来，听到他们说，酷哥保罗回他的拖车了。我走到哪儿，都有人说，酷哥保罗在洗手间，酷哥保罗在……就像必须有人随时知道我在哪里。我觉得这太搞笑了。他们必须追踪我，以确保他们在需要我时知道我在哪里。所以这是在片场一个超级有趣的故事。是的，伙计们，在电影和电视片场，有一整套
network of production assistants that wear these walkie talkies and they have little earpieces, kind of like the Secret Service, you know, but not as fancy, but not as fancy. Like when they talk into them, you hear it echo. Well, their job is literally to keep track of all the actors at all times. And you can hear them tracking you all day as you walk by, as you walk by. And sometimes you hear it from the person directly behind you who's actually speaking about you. And then you hear it in stereo from the other person they're talking to as you walk past them. And I guess the theory behind it, Jenna, is that production needs to know where we are because if the scene is lit and ready, they need us on that soundstage ready to go. And they can't have an actor unaccounted
制作助理网络，他们拿着对讲机，戴着小耳机，有点像特勤局，你知道，但没那么高级，不过没那么高级。就像当他们对着对讲机说话时，你能听到回声。好吧，他们的工作实际上就是随时掌握所有演员的动向。当路过时，你能一整天都听到他们追踪你的声音，当你走过时。有时你会直接从你身后那个实际上在谈论你的人那里听到。然后当你从他们身旁走过时，你会从他们交谈的另一个人那里听到立体声。我想背后的理论是，詹娜，制作方需要知道我们在哪里，因为如果场景打光完成并准备好了，他们需要我们在摄影棚里随时准备开工。他们不能让一个演员去向不明，
for because then that holds everyone up and it costs money, right? Yeah. So when they're lighting a scene, they let you go back to your trailer, you might use the restroom, you might get a snack. In our case, maybe we pop over to the writer's building and we're hanging out. But once the scene is ready, they have no time to lose because a production day is very regimented. And if you run out of time, that means you probably have to cut something and you don't want that, right? You don't want to have to cut content. Right. So yeah, all day long. But my favorite thing, Angela, is that they came up with a code for the bathroom. I guess maybe it's to be, I don't know, more discreet, but everyone knows what the code is. The code is 10-1. Jenna is 10-1. Everyone knows
因为那样会耽误所有人并且要花钱，对吧？是的。所以当他们在给场景打光时，他们让你回拖车，你可能会去洗手间，你可能会吃点零食。在我们的情况下，也许我们会去编剧楼串门。但是一旦场景准备好了，他们一秒钟都不能耽误，因为制作日程是非常严格的。如果你时间不够了，那就意味着你可能得删掉某些内容，而你不想这样，对吧？你不想删减内容。所以是的，一整天都是这样。但我最喜欢的是，安吉拉，他们为洗手间想出了一个代号。我猜也许是为了，我不知道，更谨慎一点，但每个人都知道代号是什么。代号是10-1。詹娜是10-1。每个人都知道
when you go to the bathroom on a set. Every single person, it goes through every walkie-talkie. Angela 10-1, Jenna 10-1. And I just want you to know, what if you need to 10-2? And you're going to be in there for a minute. Every time they would announce Jenna is 10-1, I would get a lot of anxiety because I would think I better make it fast or they're going to think I'm doing a poop. Right. What about when we both started pumping? And then you would hear in the walkie, Angela's pumping. Angela's going to pump. Yeah. All your business. All your business through a walkie-talkie. It's crazy. And I get why they have to do it, but it is very surreal. And so that clip from Paul really, Jenna and I immediately called each other. We're like, oh
当你去片场的洗手间时。每一个人，这会通过每一台对讲机传出去。安吉拉10-1，詹娜10-1。我只想让你知道，如果你需要10-2呢？而且你要在里面待上一会儿。每次他们广播詹娜是10-1时，我都会感到莫名的焦虑，因为我想我最好快点，否则他们会以为我在里面拉臭臭。对。当我们两个人都开始用吸奶器时呢？然后你会在对讲机里听到，安吉拉在吸奶。安吉拉要去吸奶了。对。你所有的隐私。通过对讲机广播你所有的隐私。太疯狂了。我理解他们为什么要这么做，但这确实非常超现实。所以保罗的那段音频，詹娜和我立刻给彼此打电话。我们心想，哦
my gosh, he talked about the thingy with the tracking. The tracking. They should warn you in film school that you're going to be tracked all day. They should warn you because it's very jarring at first. Yeah. Well, let's just say that this meeting of the five families goes very well. It also goes very quickly in about three sentences. W.B. Jones agrees. Fine. You can have your parking spaces back. It's a triumph. Listen, it looks like Kevin's about to cry. And Bill Kress is not here for that. He can't handle a grown man crying about a parking spot. And so Paul Fowles calls it. He's like, just give them their spots back. And it just wraps up so quickly. It does. And then Paul has a great line where he says this could have been an email.
天哪，他谈到了那个追踪的小玩意儿。追踪。他们应该在电影学校里警告过你，你一整天都会被追踪。他们应该警告你，因为一开始真的很让人崩溃。好吧，让我们直说，这五大家族的会面进行得非常顺利。在几句话之内也进行得非常快。W·B·琼斯同意了。好吧。你们可以拿回你们的车位。这是一场大胜。听着，凯文看起来快哭了。而比尔·克雷斯可不吃那一套。他受不了一个成年人为一个车位哭泣。所以保罗·福尔斯拍板了。他说，就把车位还给他们吧。事情就这样迅速收尾了。确实如此。然后保罗有一句绝妙的台词，他说这本可以是一封电子邮件。
Which is like a meme. It also speaks to me. Yeah. I mean, Paul needs to get out and ride his motorcycle. He's done. Kevin's talking head after this scene broke my heart. Brian did such a good job with it. He just says that after Stacy broke up with him, it was really a tough time. And well, it's just nice to win one. And he tears up. It was so sweet. Yeah. Guys, we didn't go to the character of Kevin very often for a heartfelt moment on the show. And it's a shame because Brian Baumgartner is a fantastic actor. Yeah. And you can see that in this talking head. Yeah. I was excited to get to see this performance from him. Great job, B. Oh, no. Michael has come back from his date and he's very angry. He gives a big speech.
这就像一个梗。这也说到了我的心坎里。好吧，保罗得出去骑他的摩托车了。他搞定了。这个场景之后凯文的独白让我心碎。布莱恩演得太棒了。他只是说在斯黛西和他分手后，那真是一段艰难的时期。而且，能赢一次感觉真好。他眼眶湿润了。太甜了。伙计们，我们在剧中不常让凯文这个角色展现走心时刻。这太遗憾了，因为布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳是一位极其出色的演员。是的，你在这段独白中就能看出来。我很高兴能看到他的这种表演。干得好，B。哦，不。迈克尔约会回来了，他非常生气。他发表了一大段演讲。
Angela, here are the things that he's a man of. Intensity. Cool. Youth. And passionately. He's a man of passionately. He's a man of youth and passionately. Well, at 15 minutes, 10 seconds, you might notice I'm writing on the top of my desk. I have several papers on this very little thin lip of the top of my desk. I had to do that for camera because when I was staging my writing on the actual desk, they couldn't see my face when Michael entered. I have to imagine that was a tough reach and very awkward because you're leaning over your desk to write on a tiny ledge. Well, I'll tell you something. Pam's desk was very narrow in general. I couldn't fit more than a keyboard on it in order to write on Pam's actual
安吉拉，他是一个集以下特质于一身的男人：激情、酷、青春与热情。他是一个充满激情的男人。他是一个充满青春和热情的男人。好吧，在15分10秒时，你可能会注意到我在办公桌顶部写字。我的桌子顶部那个非常薄的边缘上放了好几份文件。为了镜头我必须这样做，因为当我在真正的办公桌上摆出写作姿势时，迈克尔进来时他们就看不到我的脸了。我得想象那是一个很难够到而且非常别扭的姿势，因为你要俯身越过桌子在一个小边缘上写字。好吧，我告诉你一件事。帕姆的桌子总体来说非常窄。我没法在上面放超过一个键盘，为了在帕姆真正的
desk, which was made very thin, I think, for production. It was always awkward. Always. Yeah. So I've perched up on that little ledge, which was also awkward. In this scene, Jenna, it seems like Jim and Pam are just kind of teasing each other. Like, he's like, what were you thinking, setting Michael up with your landlord? Now you have to move out. That went horribly. And they're kind of joking. And she's like, maybe I should move in with my boyfriend. And then Pam has a moment of vulnerability and you see it in your face, Jenna, where you're going to be an advocate for yourself. This is something you've been working on. And she says, you know what? I'm only going to move in with my boyfriend if I'm engaged.
桌子上写字——为了制作需要，这张桌子被做得非常薄——总是很别扭。一直都很别扭。所以我只能蹲在那个小边缘上，那也很别扭。在这个场景中，詹娜，看起来吉姆和帕姆只是在互相调侃。比如，他说，你到底怎么想的，把迈克尔和你的房东撮合在一起？现在你得搬家了。进展糟透了。他们俩在开玩笑。然后她说，也许我应该和我的男朋友搬到一起。接着帕姆有了一个脆弱的时刻，从你的脸上能看出来，詹娜，你将为自己发声。这是你一直在努力的事情。她说，你知道吗？只有当我订婚了，我才会和我的男朋友同居。
Yeah. And Jim doesn't miss a beat. He's like, oh, it's coming. Of course. And then Pam just kind of keeps joking along. And Jenna, I was like, just Pam, I mean, in the moment, I was positive that Jim was serious. Does Pam know? Does Pam know he's doing a bit? Does it hit her that he's not? I think this maybe in my backstory was kind of one of the first times that this idea of them getting engaged or married has really come up. And that was a reason why I chose to kind of hesitate as well when Pam says, oh, I'm not going to move in with anyone until I'm engaged is because this idea of being engaged, it's not something that I thought they had talked about a lot yet. No. And that's how it, that's how it reads as an audience. I loved it because this is how
是的。吉姆连眼皮都没眨一下。他说，哦，这就要来了。当然。然后帕姆只是继续开着玩笑。詹娜，当时我想，帕姆，我的意思是，在那一刻，我敢肯定吉姆是认真的。帕姆知道吗？帕姆知道他在开玩笑吗？她有没有意识到他不是在开玩笑？我想这也许在我的背景设定中是他们考虑订婚或结婚这个想法的第一次真正浮出水面。这也是为什么当帕姆说，哦，在订婚之前我不会和任何人同居时，我选择稍微犹豫一下的原因，因为这种订婚的想法，还不是一个我认为他们已经讨论过很多的事情。没有。而这正是观众所感知到的。我太喜欢了，因为这就是
real life stuff comes up. Sometimes it just seeps in to like a mundane conversation. And then you're like, oh crap, we're here now. Okay. Yes. And so I think Pam isn't totally sure what to do with this conversation. Was it a bit? Is he being serious? Now he has a talking head for the audience where he says, oh, I'm not kidding. I got this a week after we started dating. And he shows an engagement ring. And I'm sorry, does he carry it to work with him every day? I don't know. Does it live in his pocket? Is he too worried to leave it at his apartment? Like, he hasn't ready to go. We had a fan question from Abigail B who said, is the ring Jim shows the camera the ring he proposes with later and the one that Pam wears for the rest of the show?
现实生活中事情发生的方式。有时它只是悄悄渗入一场平淡无奇的对话中。然后你会想，哦糟了，我们现在到这一步了。好吧。是的。所以我认为帕姆并不完全确定如何面对这段对话。这是个玩笑吗？他是认真的吗？现在他为观众奉上了一段独白，他说，哦，我不是在开玩笑。我们在开始约会一周后我就买了这个。然后他展示了一枚订婚戒指。对不起，他每天都把它随身带去上班吗？我不知道。它一直待在他的口袋里吗？他太担心而不敢把它留在公寓里吗？就像，他已经准备好随时拿出来了。我们有一个来自阿比盖尔·B的粉丝提问，她说，吉姆向镜头展示的戒指是他后来求婚用的那枚戒指，也是帕姆在剧集剩下的时间里戴的那枚吗？
I think it is. I think that it is. I remember Phil Shea coming up to me and presenting me with a tray of rings. And he and I had a very long conversation about what kind of ring would Jim buy Pam. Like Jim's going to hit it out of the park for Pam. Remember, Pam was always a little disappointed in her ring from Roy. That was my backstory. The cluster. Yes. And so Phil was like, what would make Pam's heart sing? And I remember picking that ring. So yeah, I think it is that ring. Pretty bold move, Jim, to buy it the first week you guys started dating. Yeah. But I guess he knew he loved her for a long time. Yeah. Well guys, here's the scene that's in Michael's office that I love. It's shot a little differently. This was Jeff Blitz. You know, there's always so many
我想是的。我认为是的。我记得菲尔·谢伊走向我，向我展示了一个托盘的戒指。他和我就吉姆会给帕姆买什么样的戒指进行了非常长时间的对话。就像吉姆要为帕姆一鸣惊人。记住，帕姆对罗伊送的戒指一直有点失望。那是我的背景设定。那个碎钻戒指。是的。所以菲尔当时问，什么能让帕姆的心欢唱？我记得我挑选了那枚戒指。所以是的，我想就是那枚戒指。真是个大胆的举动啊，吉姆，在你们开始约会的头一周就买下它。是的，但我想他知道他爱她很久了。好吧，伙计们，这是迈克尔办公室里的那个场景，我非常喜欢。它的拍摄手法略有不同。这是杰夫·布里茨拍的。你知道，
of the same scenes in the same places because we only had one set. And every once in a while, a director would find a fun way to shoot. And Jeff Blitz had this idea for this scene between Michael and Dwight that he would just lower the camera a little and shoot at an angle and slowly push in as Dwight convinces Michael that what he needs is closure. And when I watched the scene, there was a brief moment that I thought he meant with Jan. Same. He needs closure with Jan, but no. No. It's with the chair model. So they head to the cemetery of a woman he's never met. That's right. And they are going to launch into a tribute to her by singing a version of American Pie. Bye, bye, Miss Chair Model, lady. Oh, my gosh. So you know, the writers actually had a hard time
在同一个地方拍的相同场景总是很多，因为我们只有一个布景。偶尔，导演会找到一种有趣的拍摄方式。杰夫·布里茨对迈克尔和德怀特之间的这个场景有一个想法，即他稍微降低摄像机角度，从一个角度拍摄，随着德怀特说服迈克尔他需要的是释怀，镜头缓缓推进。当我看到这个场景时，有一个短暂的瞬间我以为他指的是简。我也是。他需要对简释怀，但并不是。不是的。对象是那个椅子模特。所以他们前往一个他从未谋面的女人的墓地。没错。他们将通过演唱一首《美国派》的变奏曲来向她致敬。再见，美妙的椅子模特女士。哦，天呐。所以你知道，编剧们实际上很难
getting a song cleared for this shocker. The first song they were going to parody was Elton John's Candle in the Wind, but they could not get the rights because here's an interesting bit of trivia. He had given permission for the song to be parodied on 30 Rock and he did not care for the results. So he said no more parodies of Candle in the Wind. No. Okay. They also wrote parodies of legs by ZZ Top. She's got legs. How is that a song you sing at a grave site? She was a chair model and you really see her legs in the picture. Oh, my gosh. Okay. And then also Ruby Tuesday by the Rolling Stones. Oh, I love Ruby Tuesday. But the song that got cleared was American Pie. And I'm so glad it did because I really love them in the dark singing. Well, we can't wrap up this episode
为这个令人震惊的场景弄到一首版权过关的歌。他们原本要恶搞的第一首歌是埃尔顿·约翰的《风中之烛》，但他们拿不到版权，因为这里有一个有趣的冷知识：他曾授权在《我为喜剧狂》中恶搞这首歌，但他对结果不太满意。所以他说再也不准恶搞《风中之烛》了。不。好吧。他们还写了对ZZ Top乐队的《美腿》的恶搞。她有一双美腿。这怎么能是一首在墓地唱的歌？她是个椅子模特，你在照片里确实能看到她的腿。哦，天呐。好吧。还有滚石乐队的《红宝石星期二》。哦，我喜欢《红宝石星期二》。但最终版权过关的歌是《美国派》。我太高兴它过关了，因为我真的很喜欢他们在黑暗中唱歌的样子。好吧，我们不能不看这个可爱的场景就结束这一集。
without this adorable scene. Jenna, I literally wrote adorable and highlighted it between Jim and Pam as they're walking to the satellite parking lot. And the sun is setting. You guys both look like angels. You both look so flip and adorable. Well, I remember we had to wait in our trailer for that light. That's called the magic hour. Yeah. In the biz. And there's this little 45 minutes when the sun is truly magical. Everybody take your photos at magic hour. It's when you look the best. That's right. If you're planning a wedding, plan for some like magic hour photos. Yeah. So we waited for that moment and we could only do a few takes because then we were going to lose the light. He drops to one knee. Well, I'll tell you, this moment was promod like crazy.
詹娜，我 literalmente（ literalmente 在西班牙语中是“简直”，这里翻译成“简直”）写下了“可爱”并在吉姆和帕姆走向卫星停车场的场景上做了高亮标记，当时太阳正在下落。你们俩看起来都像天使。你们俩看起来都太可爱了。好吧，我记得我们必须在拖车里等那种光线。那叫魔幻时刻。在圈内。有那么短短45分钟，太阳真的具有魔力。大家都在魔幻时刻拍照。那是你看上去状态最好的时候。没错。如果你正在筹备婚礼，那就为魔幻时刻拍些照片吧。是的。所以我们一直在等待那一刻，我们只能拍几条，因为接下来我们就要失去光线了。他单膝下跪。好吧，我告诉你，这个时刻被大肆宣传了。
I bet they blasted it out. Yeah. Well, you know, we talked about how season four was interrupted by the writer strike. The writers originally had this very, very big storyline for Jim and Pam that I think involved them moving in together if I'm correct. And instead, because we lost a bunch of episodes, they were like, you know what, we should skip that and they should just get engaged. Or we should just skip to the part where we're thinking they might get engaged any minute. And so that was where this part of the story came from. I like it. I like that Pam still had her own place. I like all of that storyline for her because you sort of feel like Pam lived with Roy for a long time. And then she finally carved out her own space in the world. And
我敢打赌他们把它大肆宣传出去了。好吧，你知道的，我们谈到过第四季是如何被编剧罢工打断的。编剧们原本为吉姆和帕姆准备了一条非常非常宏大的故事线，如果我没记错的话，其中涉及他们同居。相反，因为我们少拍了好几集，他们当时想，你知道吗，我们应该跳过那个环节，他们应该直接订婚。或者我们应该直接跳到我们觉得他们随时都可能订婚的那个部分。所以这就是这部分故事的来源。我喜欢它。我喜欢帕姆依然有自己的地方。我喜欢她身上的所有这些故事线，因为你会觉得帕姆和罗伊在一起很长时间。然后她终于在世界上开辟了自己的空间，我
I really liked that choice. Well, your reaction when you realize that Jim is faking is so great. It's so cute. You're like, I hate you. And he's like, what? It's really cute. Yeah. I have some bad news. What? I mean, spoiler alert, Pam's going to need to go to art school. We're going to frustrate you. I know this proposal is going to take a little while, but we're planting the seeds. They have to pull you guys apart to put you back together. It makes me crazy. I know. Well, guys, that is chair model. Next up is night out. I'm really enjoying season four, Angela. I have to say. Me too. So fun. And for all of you chair models out there, just know your work is not in vain. You might be inspiring others to find true love. And Paul, thank you so much for sitting in these
真的很喜欢那个选择。好吧，当你意识到吉姆是在假求婚时，你的反应太棒了。太可爱了。你说，我恨你。他说，什么？真的好可爱。好吧，我有个坏消息。什么？我是说，剧透警告，帕姆得去上艺术学校了。我们要让你们抓狂了。我知道这个求婚还要花点时间，但我们在播下种子。他们必须把你们拆散然后再把你们凑到一起。这让我快疯了。我知道。好吧，伙计们，那是《椅子模特》。接下来是《夜出》。安吉拉，我很享受第四季。我必须这么说。我也是。太有趣了。对于你们所有的椅子模特，要知道你们的工作不是徒劳的。你们可能会激励其他人找到真爱。保罗，非常感谢你发送这些
audio clips and being so quick to respond when I texted you. You are just such a delight. And I adore you. And these made our day, Jenna. And you guys, 1-800-prepare.com. Get your preparedness safety and survival information there and all the kits you might ever need. You know I'm on that. Oh, I know. I was like, oh, Paul, there's some good stuff on here. Christmas gift for me, earmark that. Survival and emergency kits and products, Jenna. We'll see you next week, everyone. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe.
音频剪辑，并且在我给你发信息时反应那么迅速。你真是个开心果。我太喜欢你了。这些让我们的一天变得很棒，詹娜。还有各位，1-800-prepare.com。去那里获取你们的应急准备、安全和生存信息以及你可能需要的所有装备。你知道我在关注这个。哦，我知道。我当时想，哦，保罗，这里有些好东西。给我的圣诞礼物，留出这个。生存和应急装备以及产品，詹娜。大家下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。